I stayed in the tent last night for the
first time in my life how was that
just the way my life is working man
I tend to uh be the worst
self-sabotage where there is you know
for 39 years all I've done is pretty
much [__] fell and [__] up at
everything I've done you know
and uh
I'm just at with what's in with it man I
just
I can't get life figured out
no
I'm just struggling
so that's all sabotage looks like what
jail prison jail prison drug use
um bad relationships with my kid
uh bad relationship with my woman
I just uh
I don't know why I can't get it figured
out but
you know
all day 39 39 and uh had a great
childhood where'd you were at uh in
Oklahoma uh like I said great childhood
raised by my grandparents good people
they don't make them like that no more
and uh where's your mom and dad
uh my real mom she did a 21 calendars
and uh in the penitentiary in Oklahoma I
was actually born at the women's prison
and uh you're born in prison yeah yeah I
guess I was kind of destined for it
that's how that was uh yeah so was my
brother and neither one of us knew our
dad so
I figured my dad was a night shift guard
or something you know I mean
conjugal visits and yeah I guess back in
the 80s you could you could uh sneak
your old man up on the yard and he'd get
out of there without making a big deal
so I guess I was destined for prison
but uh
I've been doing drugs since I was 16
years old
and um
it's just been a continual just downward
spiral
um last night I stayed in Skid Row in
Los Angeles man like I just graduated my
rehab
30 days clean and um
the second they gave me some Freedom
I'm in [__] Skid Row relapsed
I mean I just all I do is I disappoint
the people I love and I just can't get
it figured out
I mean
when I went to prison
I went to prison when I was 30 and I
figured
you can either be a shark or you can be
a seal and so
I prospected for the hearing Brotherhood
and a long story short I ended up
being the yard Captain which is uh
basically shot caller if you will for
the whites and um
I ain't going I liked it I mean you get
to point fingers and tell people what to
do and
the politics of it and can I just drink
water sure yeah
and it just
prison in Oklahoma is like the 1950s
segregated still
and
if you're white like I said you can
either [__] be a shark you can be a
seal you can be the top of the food
chain or you [__] be at the bottom
and uh I like being at the top
but it really it's what does that mean
to be uh edges out of the Aryan
Brotherhood in jail
you know and I'm not even really I'm not
racist you know I had swastikas on me
and I took them off
and it's just
when you're in prison in Oklahoma you
have to eat with your race you have to
spend time with your race if you have to
do any type of business with your race
and and if you and if you don't it's
frowned upon
and I I didn't even plan on patching out
I I was just going to go in there I had
five years to do no matter what I had a
five Island
and uh allegedly I uh took a cell phone
out of a girl's hand that was contacting
the police
and so I was charged with first degree
robbery and so they gave me five years
and uh for stealing a cell phone yeah
yeah in the state of Oklahoma if you
even induce forcedure onto anybody they
consider that robbery and uh I was in
the small town of Sapulpa and
I mean I didn't have money I didn't have
money for a big time attorney and so
when you have a public defender you
pretty much get stuck with what you got
you know and
when I went into prison I knew I had no
matter what I had to do five years
whether I was
took every [__] class there was no
matter what I had to do five and um I
was scared to death
I mean I I went into prison at 190 and I
discharged it 270.
and I mean I was it's all fake man all
these tattoos man
I I'm not a hard ass you know what I
mean I'm not known I'm not no mean
person
this is all just [__]
it's just fake man
just like I mean everything in my life
dude I'm
in complete denial like I I think every
day I got this [__] under control and
I ain't got a goddamn thing I slept in a
[__] tent last night
what's your joke
uh Fentanyl and I've been doing this
since I was 15.
but the fentanyl just started about six
months ago
and uh
it's dangerous
uh I was like I said I was 30 days clean
and I hit it last night and I almost
overdosed
and
man to be honest with you I just
I kind of in a way just wish I [__]
would have you know I mean uh
I'm just broken
I mean and and I can't get mad at nobody
but myself but
I don't know what it is man I'm being an
addict I I think I have it and I don't
you know what I mean
and I'm just I'm tired of getting high
I'm tired of not having [__] I'm tired
of [__] being a loser
and I'm tired of not being a man and my
old lady looking at me and with all of
her [__] luggage with her and
everything and I can't even support us
uh
I don't know what it's gonna [__]
take to get a wake-up call but I need
something to happen fast
and I can't go back to prison because if
I go back to prison
I gotta deal with the brothers because
of this right here
I covered my patch up
and that's a No-No from where we're from
and uh
so if I go to prison I'm gonna get
smashed out by the brothers
and so [__] my life right now man
it's just some shambles
and you know life's not that hard like
you shouldn't have to deal with problems
like this and
all I do is I complicate things and
man I just uh
what's been your darkest point
today right now today
I slept in a tent last night with my
knife out
because people were walking
by me all night long and
I was [__] high because I I relapsed
and
I don't have any money and I'm just
[__] on the streets and
I'm too scared to call home I don't want
my son knowing up
when you're in prison but uh what kind
of stuff you have to do is the head of
the
uh
as a prospect or or uh well yeah what
kind of what kind of stuff well I mean
every single one of these right here
teeth marks
you know you got a prospect first of all
you gotta you gotta the brother's gotta
even like you for you to come around you
know and once you come around
you know if if we like you at all we'll
start we'll start looking after you you
start working out with us and then
if we want to put a patch on you we'll
have you Prospect
and the prospects
whatever brother decides he wants to
prospect you you're his [__]
basically his [__] you know you have to
anything that has to be done you have to
go do you have to handle work you have
to go uh collect money you have to go uh
tell me a story
I can tell you my first mission as a
prospect
my big brother come up to me and he said
uh I need you to go across the C Unit I
need you to slap uh I can't remember
what that dude's name was
but he said he wanted me to go slap him
around when we take his TV and I take
everything he had I got a lot of scared
of shitless man like I I'm just not a
fighter man and uh basically when when
the big brother says do it do it you
gotta do it
and uh I went over there and I slapped
that guy around for no goddamn reason I
liked it
I mean as soon as I hit him in the mouth
they [__] open something up
and uh I took his TV and I walked across
the yard and took it back and uh my big
bro was [__] all excited about it and
[__] and that was day one and then
for the next year it was [__] hell
had to make knives
I had to hold whatever they [__]
wanted
for some reason I thought it was some
big you know camaraderie or whatever and
it was just a [__]
the guy those guys will turn on you and
stab you quicker than anything and
they're probably gonna [__] kick my
ass by me saying that but I don't really
give two [__] anymore you know what I
mean
something happening to yourself
I did uh
I did 91 days in the shoe
for locking sock and a child molester
um it's locking stocking well lock and
sock is uh is a tournament we use that
you know if you don't have your knife
you can take a padlock and you can tie
it on end of a sock and you get it about
that far and you can swing it and it's
it's a pretty good weapon well they knew
better to put a child molester in a cell
with me anyway
but most we call them chomos most chomos
have a look to them and little fat bald
white dude looks like he's been sitting
behind a computer all day
and so when this dude come to my cell I
didn't I didn't paperwork check them you
know you always
in prison you have your paperwork it's
like your ID tells you what what you've
been charged with
and the guy come in I asked him about
his paperwork he said he didn't have
none so right there is your first red
flag
I signed across to the brothers
always got a cell phone so he can he can
run anything
he signs back to me and says that he
raped a six-year-old girl with
instrumentation
and so at that point it was [__] time
for him to [__] get a UAB eviction
notice
and when he uh he decided he wasn't
going to go
I gave him a chance I put all the [__]
to the door and told him he could he
ain't staying here no more
and when he decided that he was going to
[__] stay I turned around and I wore
his [__] ass out with that
locking sock
I peeled him back to the white meat on
his forehead and he he proceeded to
[__] go to the front door and scream
I'm [__] killing him and so I said oh
are you a [__] rat too and I [__]
just wore his [__] ass out
and uh
in the penitentiary system they [__]
they tend to protect child molesters for
some reason so if you touch them you get
Street charges or if you [__] Haze
them or any kind of way they [__] with
you well I don't get you [__] about
that if you're a child molester
I'll [__] kill you I mean
that [__] will never be okay in my book
and after that they proceeded to bring
six uh SRT
guys to myself to make me cuff up and go
to segregation well [__] I didn't
know what the [__] I did wrong I thought
I did the world a favor
well when they decided to Cuff me up uh
I stripped down in my boxers I rubbed
baby oil all over me
and uh I was gonna make it hard as [__]
for them to [__] get get hands on me
and after the third uh verbal command
uh they sprayed me with [__] OC spray
and I dropped like a [__] it was bad
man I really [__] thought I could
[__] just dodge it and they opened up
that being home [__] shot me with it
and then uh proceeded to stick me in the
goddamn shower for two hours with butt
naked with no water no nothing
and uh that was uh day one and I was
back there for 91 days I actually had to
they gave me a blanket and uh that was
it
well day [__] 30 man like I don't
care who you are man when you're back
there by yourself
you [__] you just start talking to
yourself man like there's
I don't know if it's PTSD or what but
that [__] [__] me up man it uh
I mean
it's crazy like they wouldn't let me out
and so uh
I just decided to [__] take the only
thing I had I took the blanket and cut
it in half and I stuffed half of it in
the toilet and I took the other half and
stuffed the bottom of the door
and I had the water up to my knees and I
flooded the whole sail and I pulled the
uh pulled the towel out from the bottom
of the door and it flooded the whole top
run
and that uh that pissed off staff
sergeant and uh it still wouldn't it
still wouldn't let me out so
I busted the sprinklers [__] black
water went all over me I was madder and
[__]
I just man I was a [__] different
person in prison man I just knew no
matter what I had to do five [__]
years so it didn't matter what the [__]
I did and I was just mad at [__]
lives dude
and once I got my patch a couple other
brothers that were there uh they got
locked up and got shipped up in security
and so now all of a sudden I've had my
patch two months I've got promoted yard
captain
and once that happened that changed
everything because now they considered
me in charge
of 1500 white boys
and I can't run my own [__] life let
alone [__] prison politics
um
it was a trip man I
every day I was in the goddamn warden's
office because they uh they tend to hold
me accountable for everything a white
boy has you got your Caucasians you got
your white boys you got your brothers
there's difference okay like Caucasians
they [__] they keep to themselves
they just do their time they read their
books they [__] go to Bible study
they do [__] like that
your white boys are gonna ride with you
if you fall out with another race
because
no matter what if you fall out with
another race you gotta have everybody
that's gonna that's gonna ride with you
you're gonna go to bat for them if you
ain't gonna ride with me don't fall
don't fall in no kind of debt with any
other race because I'm not gonna [__]
come bail you out
and if you do get in debt with another
race and you're gonna go to court court
action is uh three white boys come in
there and whoop your ass so I say you're
done
you don't get in debt in prison
you know you can't you can't run nowhere
like if you borrow fifty dollars you
better have that [__] fifty dollars
on Friday
it was just a different environment I
liked I liked prison I liked the way it
was because when somebody said they was
going to do something they did it
it's not like that out here it's
changing out here people are pieces of
[__] man you can't even
nobody's words good anymore
I mean the drugs are [__] everywhere
I don't know man I'm scared to death
what's ahead for me do you have kids
yeah I got I got two kids and
my 19 year old son's my best friend and
he's been there for me you know I've
been a shitty father his whole life man
I was on drugs and then from 10 to uh 15
I was gone and
not once has he ever complained about
anything and
I know he's got some issues from me
leaving him
but man you can only uh
somebody you can only fail somebody so
many times
like I literally just talked to him on
the phone and told him I graduated
and I [__] hung up his phone and went
got high
you know
nice [__] [__] man
you know I'm not scared of one man in
this planet there's not one man this
planet scares me
but that 19 year old and 13 year old
girl scare me to death when I really
look at me and under this point you know
um
like I'm out here in [__] California
man to get clean
I get a [__] plane ticket down here
[__] kill it man I go there I excel
at [__] everything I do there man
and the second I [__] step foot out
of it I go get [__] high
I don't even know what's going on man
you're so sabotaged is that something
that comes from not having your your mom
and dad in your life man
resolved trauma that I [__]
you know I thought I'd just like to get
high you know or is it something maybe
you inherited from your Dad or Mom could
be he's up I I found him a couple years
ago he's up for parole in 2048.
that's about all I as much as the life I
have with him that's a murder
yeah I mean apparently it was in my
blood to go to prison
um
man I don't want to go back to [__]
prison because that's where I'm going
and if I can't get this [__] drug
it's drug addiction [__] under
control I'm gonna go back to prison
and they're gonna smash me out because I
covered my patch
and uh
it's [__] it's not gonna happen it's
just it's inevitable because I'm a
[__] idiot I'm a [__] up
I mean
the my life will just take some [__]
crazy turns man like I was literally in
a tent and now I'm at now I'm sitting
here doing this [__] interview with
you
hell I thought the guy that come up and
said it to me was full of [__] you know
I mean I thought it was some kind of
hustle this kid Rose a whole different
kind of Beast around here man I I never
seen nothing like it we got some
homeless back in Oklahoma but
that's a different kind out here man
these guys yeah it's a trip man
um
as far as like I don't even know what's
gonna happen when I leave here today
I don't know what the [__] I'm gonna do
I don't know if my insurance is gonna
let me ride back through again
and and you know the court system
already said if I don't complete this
[__] rehab I'm going back to prison
it's it's like you think I like [__]
prison or something you know I mean like
waiting on [__] trades and hanging
out with a bunch of dudes with that
self-sabotaging streak it's almost like
you're you're destined to repeat the
behavior yeah and I don't know why
because I've been showing every tool to
prevent all this it's almost like you
need a lobotomy or something like that
right yeah I mean I don't know what the
[__] I need I need I need my ass whooped
I know that because uh every time I've
gotten my ass whooped I ain't done it
again you know
um my girl she's struggling too you know
um
where we've been drug addicts you know
and
I I don't want to leave her I've only
been together we've been together five
years and I've been a piece of [__] to
her and she stayed there the whole
goddamn time man and it's been good as
good as she could to me
and and you know this round
you know she's tired of it and I seen it
in her face
and uh
I mean I I can't even be mad about it
man you know you can only be a certain
way to somebody for so long to where
they just give up and I see it in their
eyes I mean [__] we're in a tent you
know I mean I wouldn't be too happy with
me either
but I'm just scared she's gonna die
because she's gonna hit that fentanyl
one day and
she's gonna drop there's gonna be nobody
around her and they're gonna they're
gonna drop her off or they're gonna kick
her out of the hospital and she's gonna
be [__] dead is that your biggest
fear yeah the whole time I've been in
treatment this time she wasn't there she
was out here on the streets of LA and
she's not even from here man and she
just [__]
she just got off that she jumped out the
car on the way to treatment and she's
just been [__] God damn she's just
been winging it ever since you know what
I mean and um
when I graduated I contacted her and
found out she was still down here and
that's why I'm here
and it's not her fault you know that I
used again
I was just scared man all I could think
about was somebody [__] taking
advantage of her and and
now we're just leaving her dead
but um the common sense that would say
you know doing drugs is gonna send you
back where you came from yeah that
doesn't really work does it
common sense is just I don't even know
if it's [__] registering with me
anymore
I think I've got some type of [__]
like maybe I don't know if it's PTSD or
I just can't [__] figure life out
dude like I
get all these opportunities man and I do
great I [__] up when I'm doing good you
know I mean I don't ever [__] up when
I'm like out here in the tent you know
what I mean I [__] up when the you know
I got 10 acres I got a brand new truck I
got a great job
you know I mean that that's when I [__]
up I don't know what it is man maybe
it's some emotions that I don't
recognize but it sounds like the like
borderline personality disorder or
something like that it could be you know
what I mean you just are gonna because
I'm [__] telling myself I'm [__]
doing all right and I'm not doing all
right you know
uh I think a lot of it is is just
this fake persona I have man I [__]
of me being confident me being [__]
big and strong and and me having
everything under control and I don't man
I don't have nothing under control
like I didn't I don't have a dollar to
my name right now and when I leave here
I don't know what the [__] I'm gonna do
and
I I'm scared you know because it's
different out here but
I don't know man sometimes I wish I'd
just [__]
hit that Fentanyl and hold it in you
know I mean and just [__]
you know I'm not wanting to kill myself
so long but you know don't put me in a
[__] crazy suit but man sometimes you
just think about [__]
everything that's going on all the
people I hurt you know
because I'm good I'm good at hurting
people I love I'm I'm and I'm a gold
star piece of [__] on uh on drugs you
know I mean
um
I just don't know I don't know what to
do in this next step man I mean I'm I'm
at a loss
and uh
the [__] I guess you could say I've
hit rock bottom you know what I mean
um
I literally [__] sat down on my bags
earlier and watch the dude take a [__]
in the corner right next to me man it
was [__] totally normal to him you
know what I mean and he just went on his
[__] way yep you're in Skid Row
there's there's new levels of rock
bottom right right and uh I don't want
to live my life like that no more man
and I don't know what I need to do to
change it but
you know I'm not a real spiritual person
but
I'm gonna pray today you know
and I mean I don't even know who the
[__] I'm praying to but
I need some help
man uh
I don't know if this store will do
anything for anybody you know it could
be good to listen to and
but that's what my life is today
yeah you need something yeah I need
something whether it's Jesus or lobotomy
or whatever yeah good kick in the ass
maybe a good kick in the ass yeah
all right thank you so much for sharing
your story yeah I'm sorry good luck in
the world man yeah sorry uh when if I
wouldn't have been so [__] high right
now I probably would have ordered that
better you did great